everyone i'm abby sharpe welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today we're taking a look at episode 2
of jaclyn hill's weight loss journey now
if you're new to the series jaclyn is
documenting her struggles with weight
loss her relationship with food and the
pressures of being on social media in a
tell-all series revealing what her life
is really like technically i think it's
been about
three weeks since i started this whole
60 day thing
um the whole 60-day thing is not i don't
want to say it's not obtainable it is i
have that i'm gonna eat a sandwich
oh sometimes it's just worth it okay a
double double regular with just grilled
onions regular fries and a chocolate
shake i don't know
i'm like a little miss piggy okay
i have absolutely no regrets
[Music]
nothing was worth it to me
this looks like something that you would
find in a diaper honestly
[Music]
now of course before we get into it feel
free to pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a huge trigger warning to
those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating as
always please feel free to skip this
video if it's not supportive to your
journey and if you're new here welcome
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel ring that bell and also follow
me over on social media on instagram and
on facebook and on tick tock where i am
taking down all the nutrition bs on the
regular all right let's dive in i'm
super hormonal i'm pmessing really bad
and of course this is the time to make
excuses when you start your period
you're like okay like come on i get to
eat ice cream i get to have cookies like
the cravings are worse right
so trying to really power through that
okay so let's take a second here to
normalize period cravings because i
think the word cravings in general has
gotten a really bad rep as something
that you need to suppress or prevent
when really it just means like the foods
that you want to eat period no pun
intended but there is actually a
scientific rationale for our period
cravings thanks to the appetite
stimulating effects of progesterone
which arises right before you period and
the appetite suppressing effects of
estrogen which falls around that time
now serotonin levels also take a dive
which not only explains our not so sunny
disposition but also can trigger a
desire for carbs to help boost the
serotonin in the brain now this is all
just to say that increased cravings
particularly for carbs actually have an
evolutionary and biochemical explanation
and since rising progesterone levels
actually cause a modest increase in
metabolic rate of up to 12 or more
research does suggest that there's kind
of this unconscious compensatory
mechanism in place to help maintain
weight homeostasis in other words your
body's got your back so this is not
something that we should necessarily try
to fight or fear i actually have a whole
video on what to eat during different
stages of your cycle here if you want
some more evidence-based tips i'm going
to eat a sandwich whole sandwich with
bread and everything i got an italian
syrup from potbellies i'm going to be
good i'm also going to indulge okay so
based on the paltry portions that we saw
in episode one i'm really not surprised
that jaclyn's got to this trip with an
overwhelming urge to
actually eat we often see dieters get
into vacation mode eating like all the
forbidden things the moment the plane's
wheels get off the ground
[Music]
now i want to of course flag that i
would never classify a sandwich as like
an indulgent food but based on her
attitude i am worried that since she's
kind of broken her safe pattern of
dieting at home that this sandwich is
like the kickoff to a last supper style
eating event in la let's hope
that i'm wrong no you're not wrong i'm
so sad i don't get to have the vibe
but it's okay i'm saving my car for my
lobster rollator and mouth oh
it's so wavy it's good no it's not good
their buns slapped so hard it's so
crunchy on the inside and soft on the
outside this is so lame give the five
off the buns at 10.
i'm gonna be happy about it okay so
jaclyn says that she's saving her carbs
for the lobster roll later on so it
sounds like she's trying to maintain
some semblance of her diet while away
but what's the point of getting the
lettuce bun if it's just gonna make you
miserable i worry that this is just a
setup for a binge
this is like my first real cheat i'm
eating that whole lob server right there
i'm going in
[Music]
you feel good about this cheat
oh yeah
like little miss piggy okay
i don't want to say i told you so but
also
cheat probably my second least favorite
c word in the dictionary behind cleanse
i don't think that there's anything
wrong with any of the meals that she
enjoyed there and i'll talk more about
that in a sec but i would hedge a better
that if she just allowed herself that
little bun that she wanted so badly
earlier on in the day that she probably
wouldn't likely need or want to eat all
the fries in her kind of first cheat of
the day and also she were truly
listening to her body's needs and wants
and not just being in like diet starts
tomorrow cheat day mentality she
probably would have been craving a
little more veggie action by dinner now
having said that i'm actually a bit
relieved to see jacqueline getting in
some more protein and carbs and also
choosing foods that she enjoys and
there's actually a lot of nutritious
ingredients here worth regularly
enjoying but i'd love to see these kinds
of foods worked into her diet more often
so it's not to trigger some kind of last
supper kind of cheat weekend something
that i've realized is that when i
decide to like cheat in like little ways
like cheese and crackers i hate it like
i feel like crap afterwards like i feel
bloated i feel nasty but when i go in
for a banger cheat like a huge bowl of
pasta or like last night when i had the
enchiladas that for some reason brings
me happiness i feel no guilt i feel
nothing negative towards myself i'm like
that was so worth it i have
lots of questions first
why are cheese and crackers thought of
as a cheat because i personally see
cheese and crackers as you know fiber
protein and fat aka the hunger crushing
combo not something to feel ashamed
about now if she feels like crap after
eating cheese and crackers physically i
of course think it's important to gather
that data and find another snack but if
she feels like crap because of like the
guilt then it's worth asking yourself
what about cheese and crackers elicits
such a moral knee-jerk reaction now it
does sound to me that jaclyn heavily
leans on food for emotional support
since she claims that the big cheats
make her happy but i would love to see
her work to find things that bring her
joy outside of large amounts of food and
that's something that you know maybe she
could work with a professional to figure
that one out i'm fine with like having a
huge cheat like that and then waking up
and getting back to it and it's like
having the foundation of like eating
healthy 90 of the time and like that's
who you are in your normal life but then
like going out of town and like having
things here and indulging here and there
it's like that's fine who cares so first
of all i'm really happy that jacqueline
has found something that's working for
her that she can feel proud of and i
will say that i get that a lot of
dieters feel more in control when they
diet really hard and then eat all the
things to kind of like get it out of
their system more than getting back on
the dieting train the next day now when
i was struggling with my eating disorder
i also thought that this helped me kind
of stay more in control but the reality
is
that i was the farthest thing from being
in control and it also doesn't sound to
me that just getting back to it is so
easy when it requires you to obsess over
food all day and then kind of fantasize
over the next big cheat and even if
these kinds of foods don't force
jacqueline to crave them all day every
day after she has this cheat it doesn't
sound to me that just kind of getting
back to it is so easy when it causes you
to obsess over food all day long and
then fantasize over the next big cheat i
would think that that's something that
we could work on so i'm happy to hear
that she's maybe craving some fresher
healthier foods now of course she's
listening to her body but i would say
that that's a piece that i would want
her to work to unpack all i've had today
is a cheeseburger that was wrapped in
lettuce from in and out and i only had a
half of it because i didn't like it it
was soggy and it was gross what about
breakfast this morning in malibu
i had two bites of a donut okay what
i have a drink i have a shot of vodka
with um flavored salsa water because
when i drink i drink clean it's honestly
kind of sad to hear that jaclyn
constantly has to justify her food
decisions like cheeseburger that was
wrapped in lettuce i had two bites of a
donut because when i drink i drink clean
also why is she choosing the lettuce
wrap cheeseburger again when she clearly
hated the last one she ate again i would
bet that if she were able to shake the
scarcity mentality on vacation she might
find herself craving more nutrient-rich
meals honestly without the dichotomous
dieter hat on a colorful salad would
likely be much more physically and
emotionally satisfying than some kind of
soggy cheeseburger
these jeans
were fitting me so perfect five days ago
i wore them i just put them on
and they are so tight i could barely
button them and that's just from me
sneaking some little bites of you know a
donut you know or having like a full
plate of enchiladas honestly
one serving of enchiladas and a few
bites of a donut does not hold that type
of power so don't give it to it you know
blaming your bad food choices is so
unnecessarily punishing when the more
likely cause of tight pants is maybe
some water retention or a change in
bathroom habits which is very typical
when traveling cause i
rip my pants let's try to have a little
more compassion here this is so much
food
oh this is going to be we're feeding an
army muffler
eat like
all day long it's gonna suck me back to
florida and getting back on the grind
but low-key i'm so excited i cannot wait
i'm really looking forward to getting
home because i'm i'm over it i'm
exhausted the classic i ate like i'll
start fresh again tomorrow mentality
that takes us on a endless cycle we
restrict which triggers a binge leading
to guilt and then harder restriction now
if we were framed i ate like today to
something a bit more compassionate like
i gave myself permission to enjoy the
foods that i was depriving myself of we
can help remove the morality we kill the
dichotomy we add back the human like
you've been subsisting off of 500
calories a day and you're now surrounded
by all of your favorite foods like give
yourself a break you don't need to be
better you need to be kinder your body
is literally just fighting to survive we
are back home in tampa we don't have any
groceries as of right now so i ordered
grilled mahi mahi
rice and veggies i shouldn't be eating
this rice i was like so starving i was
like i need i need rice okay notice the
contradiction here i shouldn't be eating
this rice versus i was starving so i
needed this rice it is clear to me that
her body and her mind are on two very
different pages also willing to bet that
she likely felt very good physically
after this meal not only because she was
super hungry but also because it was
inherently balanced you know we've got
protein and fat from the mahi mahi we
got carbs from the rice and some veggies
on the side but unfortunately because
she quickly diagnosed and categorized
this meal as morally bad thanks to the
rice she wasn't able to collect that
data on how it actually made her feel
day one back in tampa what do we got
ezekiel toast
bacon tomato arugula
egg
and cheddar cheese smoked cheddar cheese
this is a drastic improvement from the
breakfast that we saw in her previous
video so we've got carbs from the toast
protein and fat and the eggs bacon and
cheese and some veggies from the tomato
and arugula balanced and clearly
enjoyable it's a small portion for sure
but i would say if this is what her
fresh start looks like then i'm totally
on board the past five days being out of
town i basically ate whatever i wanted
whatever i wanted especially because i
was working so much and i'd be like in a
pinch treating my body like crap i
didn't take any my vitamins while i was
gone i didn't drink enough water while i
was gone i have so much indigestion
from
the way i've treated my body and
heartburn i just felt like absolute crap
i'm considering today like a fresh start
i'm gonna take care of myself gonna
hydrate all day gonna eat well and not
allow the last five days to throw me off
track so i think it's great that
jacqueline is gathering this data for
herself and kind of noting that this
pattern of eating doesn't make her feel
great physically or emotionally but i
think what jacqueline fails to consider
is that this has less to do with any
kind of lack of willpower or the types
of food and more to do with simply not
eating enough the rest of the time had
she been eating sufficient calories
prior to her trip she may have been more
likely to make more mindful decisions
rather than kind of going balls the
walls to the point where she had to
throw up from indigestion
[Music]
what is that
it looks like bread to me i'm being so
bad but it feels so good
cheese fried balls
i actually the
again
here we go right like we're bouncing
between eating a lot restricting eating
a lot restricting repeat repeat repeat
but if we allowed ourselves enough food
that actually satisfied carbs wouldn't
need to run our life they could just
simply be part of our life and they
could be a part that we wouldn't have to
devote so much energy to thinking about
you guys i've talked about this i am
such a snacker i love to snack and munch
so bad i cannot do three meals a day
like i don't understand how anyone can
just have like breakfast lunch and
dinner like i need to put something in
my mouth
like every hour and a half i'm just
trying to find some stuff that can keep
me sane so as i mentioned in my previous
video one of the likely reasons why
jacqueline feels the need to snack
constantly is because she's just not
having enough protein with her meals
awesome i love protein i know you love
protein i love protein too yeah protein
rocks which is making her both
physically and psychologically
unsatisfied so it's clear that she's
kind of on this satisfaction hunt all
day long but i do actually see lots of
options for hunger crushing combos here
in her hall so we could mix some hummus
with the tortilla chips and veggies or
do some popcorn mixed with some nuts for
a really satisfying little trail mix
just options because like the flavor
that i'm looking for oh like it's still
better than eating fried chicken for
lunch i saw on tick-tock some girl was
like making like a her like healthy
snack and it was like a protein smoothie
and she added oreos in it and people
were like this is not healthy but she
was saying that she lost weight in the
smoothie but it's like i understand
because if you have a sweet tooth and
you allow yourself that every once in a
while you're still going to lose weight
it's about balance okay so in this clip
jaclyn is talking about an avocado tuna
salad that she made that she didn't love
but she's trying to weigh out the
unhealthiness of the mercury in the tuna
versus like the fat in fried chicken
first of all just an fyi but canned
albacore tuna is not particularly high
in mercury so authorities suggest we can
enjoy it safely about once a week but
light or skip jack tuna is even lower
with 0.13 parts per million of mercury
so authority suggests that it can safely
be enjoyed by adults two to three times
per week as for the greater sentiment
here this is an important realization so
i agree that if putting oreos in your
smoothie makes it more enjoyable for you
to get in a breakfast with you know some
protein and healthy fats this is a great
hack it's exactly what i did in my
hunger crushing combos video right here
so yes it's all about asking yourself
what foods would help me make healthy
eating more sustainable and enjoyable
long term i just don't want to get
discouraged especially because i just
fell off the last week so hardcore i
can't like hit it so hard and expect
myself to be like okay cutting
everything like i have to like take it
slow okay so it sounds like jaclyn knows
what to do yet she's having a little bit
of trouble executing him so she knows
that she has to take it slow and she
shouldn't eliminate everything she loves
all at once and she knows that she's
allowed to eat the foods that she enjoys
she knows it's about balance she says
those things out loud but then in other
clips she's talking about starting fresh
and being so bad and lamenting over
eating foods that she shouldn't so this
is why having a dietitian on her team
would really help her navigate these
challenges and also help her execute as
well so you guys having hard-boiled eggs
is an absolute lifesaver for me because
in that midday moment where i'm like oh
my god i'm losing my mind i just crack
open a hard-boiled egg put some salt on
it and it holds me over for a while we
made the salad from tiktok which is just
tomatoes olives red onions and cucumbers
and then salt pepper and some lemon
juice so yummy yes i love that we've got
some meal prep going on this definitely
makes it so much easier to make more
mindful decisions about what to eat when
you've kind of got all the meal
components at the ready and we have 18
different toppings
is there any way that you could do all
of them the works you got and also i'm
so happy to see her focus on protein and
not just a ton of low calorie vegetables
which she also notes herself will help
to satisfy her hunger longer i think
it's been about
three weeks since i started this whole
60 day thing the whole 60 day thing is
not i don't want to say it's not
obtainable it is i was doing so good i
lost seven pounds in like two weeks
amazing i know a ton of it was water
weight but who cares got on the flight
went to la and everything just went
i let myself cheat a lot i'm gonna eat a
sandwich chocolate sticks
it's like once you taste a little bit of
it you just want to keep going i'm just
discouraged in the sense that like i
just make excuses for everything by here
and it's one bite there and that racks
up in your body and it ends up counting
and it ends up making you bloated and
feeling like crap so i'm getting back on
track starting today i woke up had a
green smoothie i had a salad for lunch
is anyone listening to me listen to me
carefully here's the thing there's
always going to be life events that
revolve around food so whether it's
vacations long weekends birthdays
football parties etc and if you do not
heal your relationship with food you're
going to perpetually live in this yo-yo
state of like full-blown cheat weeks to
green juice cleanses and like she said
that inconsistency doesn't feel good so
she was totally right when she said that
this whole 60 day thing is not
obtainable it's not obtainable because
it's not real life and she didn't [ __ ]
up she was just living real life and i
really hope that she can find it in her
to be more compassionate about this
moving forward because this is not a
quick
fix it's not just about the food and
it's not just about the weight so given
what we've seen so far from jaclyn's
journey it's pretty clear that we're
stuck on this kind of binge restrict
hamster wheel with no real end in sight
now i'm happy to hear that she started
to collect some data on what foods feel
good and maybe not so good but her
ability to act on this data seems to be
clouded by her kind of black and white
dichotomous thinking around what is good
or bad to eat a healthy diet shouldn't
just be green smoothies and avocado and
eating a donut on vacation or popcorn at
the movies won't automatically undo
everything healthy either it's really
about finding a balanced way to
integrate these foods that feels
nourishing satisfying and morally value
free so on that note that is all that i
have for you guys today if you liked it
be sure to give it the thumbs up and
also leave me a comment below if you'd
like to see more commentary on jaclyn's
series subscribe to the channel and i'll
see you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]
you